this is the most disrespectful statistic
I have ever seen in my life this one
surprised me probably the most and it's
the fact that Hikaru Nakamura has been
given a 9% chance a whopping 9% chance
to win the Champions chess tour finals
hi I'm Levy Rosman but you might know me
as Gotham chess and I'm Daniel nitzki
you might know me as the prophet we're
here to predict who's going to win the
Champions chess tour final starting
December 9th in Toronto we'll be in
Toronto live to comment the action the
best players in the world have battled
all year long for eight Elite spots
here's our take on their chances to win
it all da so Ali RZA is the youngest
ever player to get to 2800 but this year
on the tour he struggled in particular
against Magnus and also recently his
rating is down like never before and
he's probably not going to be making the
feta candidates what do you estimate as
his chances to win the Champions Chester
finals so 5% sounds very low like leevy
but I actually think that's a pretty
legitimate prediction given his results
across the time controls uh since he
sort of came back from his break we have
to factor in that he hasn't played chess
nearly as regularly as almost everybody
else in the field he struggled In
classical and he's kind of lacked that
spark you know that excitement uh in his
play that inspiration that passion that
propelled him to 2800 that's kind of
been missing uh in his latest tournament
performances and I think he needs to
bring that back uh if he wants to you
know raise eyebrows this year in the CCT
finals and something tells me that he
might not have the form to do that just
yet personally I think Ali Reza is the
biggest wild card in the field da so
even if he's had a bad year even if he's
had a bad run he's out of form he
doesn't have a great record against some
of these players it might actually be to
his benefit he has some pressure off his
shoulders now that he doesn't have to go
into another candidates and potentially
risk it being a disaster so maybe he
does find that fire walk around Toronto
get inspired eat some good food and uh
he does really well like I think he's
the most unpredictable player in the
field it could be 5% it could be
negative 5% could be 25% we'll just have
to see which Ali Resa shows up so
there's no question that Fabiano has had
an absolute Resurgence he's been
confident he's been winning so many
games and this is the Fabiano that we
saw you know score eight out of eight in
the 2015 singfield this is the Fabiano
that qualified for the world
championship and we've been tracking The
Narrative where fabibi has improved
exponentially in faster time controls as
well so he's got a lot going for him uh
with that said I still think Fabiana has
a lot to prove uh in the rapid time
control I think 18% uh is right about on
the dot uh he needs a lot of things to
go right for him uh he needs to do well
against Magnus but if Fabby can continue
his form and channel that confidence I
think he's got a great shot Levy so I
have a problem with several things that
you just said number one in 2015 Fabiano
caruana went one win and three losses in
the singfield cup so I certainly hope
that Fabiano caruana does not show up uh
if uh he wants a chance to win I believe
it was
2014 2014 when he won his first seven
games including one against Magnus
Carlson uh but yes you're 100% right in
the fact that he is back over 2800 he's
had a bit of a Resurgence number two in
the world uh once again and basically
anytime he's now a member of a
tournament you might hypothesize that
he's going to win it but I
also strongly disagree with this
conclusion that he has double the
statistical chances which we will get to
later of that hikaro has of winning the
Champions chest tour finals I find that
kind of hard to believe because I am of
the opinion that hikaro is the second
best chess player in the world if you
take all formats and Fabiano is probably
number three so I have a personal
disagreement with the statistics but I
also didn't crunch the
numbers so believe it or not Nock
abdulov is actually the only other
player in this field not named Magnus
Carlson to be a world rapid chess
champion and yet having said that he has
a 3% estimated chance of winning the
entire thing for me personally Nock is a
bit of a mystery he clearly has ice cold
water in his veins he's going to be a
fantastic competitor uh when the
pressure is at its highest but does he
have the skill set necessary to adapt to
every single player does he have the
preparation uh in the openings in this
faster time control than a classical to
perform the stats don't say so in fact a
handful of these players have a higher
chance of winning according to the
statistics than Nock Dan I'm curious to
hear your thoughts why is he only listed
as a 3% yeah I think mystery is a great
way to put it Levy he clearly has shown
that he is capable of defeating every
player in this field and he's beaten
Magnus uh in a classical time control
with black he's beaten him uh in Rapid I
think on route to winning uh that rapid
Championship but but with that said he's
one of the less experienced players in
the field he hasn't been uh 2700
classical for all that long uh and
recently he hasn't played badly but he
hasn't shown that the same level of
Brilliance that it would take to win
this event so while 3% is a little bit
harsh I think given some of the other
competitors like Karu and Magnus I
actually think it's a pretty fair
prediction I think that his objective
skill set is quite a bit inferior uh to
players like mvl Carlson uh Hikaru even
Ali Reza so nottock will have to
essentially play the tournament of his
life he might even have to show a
performance Superior to that which won
him the world rapid and objectively
that's pretty
unlikely I don't associate MBL with 2720
I associate him with 2780 2800 so he has
the capability to win this tournament
there's no question about it but I don't
know just something tells me that he's
just hasn't had enough classical
practice hasn't had enough OTP practice
so I'm a little bit pessimistic about
mv's chances 7% I'm not very good with
the exact numbers I think that's the
right ballpark Levy yeah for me it's
also very difficult to look at Maxim and
see a number of 7% to win the entire
event and just like you said to also see
his world ranking because Maxim to me is
a 3,000 Plus on chess.com Blitz player
he's a ridiculous uh rapid and and Blitz
player skill-wise he's a former World
Blitz Champion just a couple of years
ago so to see where he's fallen in the
world rankings is quite strange at the
same time we we're currently witnessing
a Changing of the Guard in the the Chess
World guys like prananda Vincent kimer
no abaturov Ali Resa fuja just to name a
few they have to take their rating from
somebody and they are taking their
rating points from guys like Maxim
Hikaru Fabiano dingl Ren Yan pomi Magnus
Carlson those guys are still perennial
top five players then you have the
perennial top 10 and unfortunately Maxim
has fallen out of that perennial status
so at any given moment 2800 level Maxim
could show up World Blitz Champion Maxim
could show up this could could be that
tournament but I do take issue with the
fact that he is more than double likely
to win this event over a guy like nck
who's clearly the future generation of
the game so that's where I have my
gripes not to mention the fact that MV
also has a higher chance to win this
thing than alira like we could have a
whole separate debate about that but I
know that the country of France is going
to be rooting heavily for him his games
are going to be covered on Blitz streams
channel so we'll see how mvl does France
has two players to root for in this
event but I don't fancy their chances
against guys like hikaro Fabiano or
Magnus last year in Toronto Wesley so
won the entire event that event was
called the global Chess Championship
this event is called the Champions chess
tour finale now there's a key
distinction between last year and this
year last year Magnus Carlson was not
present also those games were played on
screens actually this year the players
as we know are going to be playing on
physical chess sets now we actually
don't know how Wesley performs in Elite
rapid tournaments because he hardly ever
if ever has played a world rapid Chess
Championship why those dates fall right
after Christmas and during that time
Wesley is at home with his family which
is an entire separate conversation we
should have as to why those dates fall
on literally the most inconvenient
travel dates of the year but we're not
going to do that right now Wesley so has
a 7% chance according to our metrics of
winning the Champions chess tour finals
I don't know how I feel about that
number simply because Maxim was given
the exact same 7% if we're going to say
Maxim gets 7% I think Wesley's probably
more at a 10% he matches up really well
against players he is generally very
very well prepared he's probably a top
three to top five rapid chess player in
the world but it is still a mystery to
me da how he's going to perform live
over the board against some of the best
players in the world cuz we don't get to
see that very often I agree and I think
if we were making these predictions
after the global chess champion uh
finals which which Wesley I almost said
which Levy won um wish You'll wish
you'll win it next time uh which Wesley
won I think I made the same mistake uh
during commentary I would call you
Wesley and I would call Wesley Levy so I
don't know what that says but Wesley has
been a shadow of his former self uh for
the last last year it's not that he's
been blundering a lot he just hasn't
played with any spark he's making tons
of draws and you know he's almost been
unrecognizable tournament after
tournament and you know the Wesley that
won the cgc finals last year and the
Wesley that played in the US
championship for example are two
completely different people and somehow
I just don't see Wesley suddenly
reemerging in this tournament I think 7%
is approximately correct of course he
might find his form you never no but if
Wesley continues to play you know the
kind of sterile chess that that he's
been showing recently I just there's
just no way that he's going to defeat
Hikaru and Carlson and you know a hungry
ala fua I just don't really see it
happening honestly this
year this is the most disrespectful
statistic I have ever seen in my life I
almost wish the stats team added
decimals like is it
0.4% and they just rounded down is it
maybe 0.8% but they couldn't round that
up because that would be an
embellishment of the reality I mean I
find it so ridiculous that they're
saying like we doctor stranged it we saw
14, 305,000 possibilities and in none of
them does Dennis lazovic win this
tournament why did he even take the
plane here I mean I guess like does he
does he get a check for getting last
place or sixth place I guess this odds
is for winning right now a better
statistic would be what are his chances
of advancing what are his chances of
winning one of the head-to-head matchups
what are his chances of making the
quarters or or rather not the quarters
the semi-finals let's say something like
that that's a more interesting debate
but unfortunately the statistic is to
win it which is really unfair in a field
of let's say a guy like Magnus Carlson
and then hikaro Fabiano and all the
other great players well it's definitely
not ridiculous because let's reverse
engineer the 0% imagine if Dennis
lazovic wins the CCT finals that will
probably be the greatest Underdog Story
in like sports history it's going going
to completely surpass like the fact that
the Miami Heat as the eighth seed made
the finals last year it'll be the most
outlandish story ever um so if you track
that back yeah 0% is pretty realistic
given who lazic has to be now this is
absolutely not a reflection on his
talent he's an incredible player with at
this point a great track record of
success in Blitz and Rapid time controls
he does well in title Tuesday uh he's
defeated shakar midara actually two
times in a row uh so he's
I think in in an individual game he can
beat anybody including Magnus Carlson
but if you understand what it takes to
make the CCT finals 0% starts to make
more sense it's harsh but once again if
lavic manages to win this tournament I
mean this will be talked about for years
to
come this one surprised me probably the
most and it's the fact that hearon
Nakamura has been given a 9% chance a
whopping 9% chance to to win the
Champions chess tour finals mostly this
is in context of other statistical uh
probabilities for example Fabiano
caranas is 18% likely Wesley and Maxim
are 7% each which I find to be
ridiculous Karu probably deserves at
least 5 to 7 percentage points more I
don't know who you take that out of and
when I think Karu I think probably
something like 20% having said that in
2022 he failed to win the global uh
Chess Championship and that was because
of a really odd match against Wesley so
where they just played really really
solid games Non-Stop and then hikaro
ended up losing one so that's where it
gets a bit strange for me I mean hikaro
is like the number one to win or uh
Blitz and bullet events like the speed
chest Championship he and Magnus go down
to the wire uh every single time that
they play why is he only 9% this is the
biggest mystery to me can can you you
help me unpack this I definitely take
issue with the 9% I think that chess
fans should keep in mind that in general
the differences in strength among these
players are so incredibly low and this
is what makes predictions so difficult
for an event like this I mean people
always ask me on stream who do you think
is going to win X Y and Z and the
margins are incredibly thin essentially
any player can beat any other player in
a given match and I think a lot of
people don't really understand that they
think of things in these Global absolute
okar going to just Crush everybody but
in one individual match mvl can
absolutely beat hikaro and so that's why
I wouldn't put hikaro at like 50% and
Magnus at 50% these other players if
they show good form can absolutely
defeat any other player with that said I
agree I mean 9% versus 18% for Fabiano I
take great issue with that if anything I
would just flip the two I would put
hikaro at 18% and Fabiano at 9% I think
that would be an easy way to resolve
things while keeping uh the added
percentages up to to 100 at least I
think that's the way math Works don't
really remember fifth grade but yeah I
think that's an issue and definitely if
you take Karu like versus mvl
objectively I think yaru has a much much
higher chance of winning yeah the the
weirdest thing for this statistic for me
is isn't Hikaru the favorite in every
single matchup except maybe against
Magnus exactly like how is he only 9% it
doesn't make any sense he is the heavy
favorite against Fabby in a rapid I mean
this is like the fact that I will cling
to if hikaro versus Fabby iaro has had
his absolute number he's been crushing
Fabby 20 move game in aisle of man wiped
the floor with him in sec I mean surely
that has to count for something and
don't call me Shirley but yeah I mean
that that I have the biggest issue with
with with these predictions is is maybe
the hikaro Fabby numbers uh even though
I'm contradicting myself Levy but
honestly when I was talking about Faby I
forgot to check hikaru's percentage now
that I'm thinking about it yeah hikaro
absolutely should be at like 18
20% so in the case of Magnus I would
almost like draw a parallel to a regular
walking into you know their favorite
restaurant and all of the tables are
booked and they don't have a reservation
but because you've been a patron of this
restaurant for years and years a table
is always going to be made ready for you
so it almost doesn't matter who else is
playing in the tournament what magnus's
recent results were if he's in a
tournament he is just the favorite the
heavy favorite by definition I mean this
is the respect that he's earned over his
his years of dominance and 50% is an
incredibly High number Magus has been
upset in a lot of recent tournaments but
I mean his level of dominance is such
that I do think that he's the heavy
favorite and I do think that when Magnus
plays with not a lot on the line and I
think in the CCT he's been he's going to
be playing freely uh he's not as worried
anymore about having something to prove
he's won everything there is to win so
in a certain sense I think there's the
least amount of pressure on Magnus in
another sense he's got the biggest X on
his back everybody wants to be that
player who upsets Magnus in in any
tournament but especially on a stage as
high as the CCT so maybe 50% uh is a
little bit over optimistic but maybe
like 15% of that just comes from the
respect that we have to give Magnus
because he's Magnus
Levy that's true Magnus could be 75
years of age and go to his favorite
restaurant no no and they'll still have
a table Magnus could play uh the 200 uh
63 edition of this tournament and he
will still have more of a chance than
Dennis lvic uh
um yeah guy statisticians uh really
really poor Dennis um no but on a
serious note I almost feel 50% is
slightly under hear me out they ran the
simulation right if this event happens
10,000 times Magnus loses this event
5,000 times like he doesn't win it he
gets second third isn't that almost too
many times right that's just too many
times so I I don't know from who he
would absorb the percentage points
but I almost feel like it could be 55 or
60 because as you said when Magnus
participates he wins that's what he does
uh and he wins rapid he wins Blitz he is
the reigning uh World rapid and Blitz
Champion he's no longer the classical
world
champion but everybody knows he's still
the best chess player in the world
so I think the odds are pretty fair I
think the rest of the field has to look
to upset him and take him out whether
that's going to be early or late I just
hope that we get a Magnus versus hikaro
finale all agree on that yes I think we
can we can all agree on that I think all
eyes will be on that but whoever is in
the finals whether it's Hikaru whether
it's any of the other
participants uh we do have a very high
expectation that Magnus wins the event
but we won't know until the players
start moving the little figurines to
their little squares thank you everybody
for watching our predictions uh I think
what makes this event most exciting is
precisely the fact that it's so
difficult to make predictions if it was
easy if we knew exactly who the
favorites were there wouldn't be the
same level of fighte I'm so excited to
see the battle of the generations how
players like Dennis lazic who might not
have a big chance to win the whole event
uh might be able to play spoiler I'm
very very excited for a potential
Carlson versus Saro match um it's going
to be an amazing event the hype and we
don't have to manufacture the hype this
is the amazing thing the hype comes from
the chess itself uh these amazing
matchups it's going to be an unmissable
event me personally I'm obviously
looking forward to seeing some of the
best chess players of the world compete
but I'm equally and if not more excited
for the event to actually be in Toronto
for the first time for there to be a fan
Zone viewing experience we're all going
to sit patiently and wait for a matchup
that we all expect and all want and all
dream and crave for Magnus versus hikaro
but we've got Fabiano we have mvl fuja
nck all these uh young guys in the mix
as well I apologize if I didn't name any
names specifically but it's a great
field in a great City da we were there
last year the the atmosphere the buzz in
Toronto is is electric and I don't think
Toronto uh I don't think you could
choose a better City to play host to
such an event and then in the second
quarter of the next year we have the
candidates tournament itself which is
going to be in Toronto so I'm pumped I'm
really looking forward to this event
thank you all so much for hanging out
with us and listening to our predictions
whether we aligned with yours or you
think we're idiots and we'll see you all
there December 9th through 16th in
Toronto